CHRIS DIBONA: Hi.
My name is Chris DiBona.
I look after open source
software and a science outreach
group for the company--
the company being Google, for
the people watching on YouTube.
I guess I got to
meet Rob because I
used to work with his
wife some 17 years ago.
And then I got to
meet Rob while he
was banging his head against
the music business with Rhapsody
and we were doing TV.
So the long and
short of it is, Rob
rejected all this
technology business stuff
and decided to become
a science fiction
author, which was very
endearing, of course,
to all of us.
And so I don't want to
spend a lot of time on me.
I want Rob to kick it off.
Oh, I will say the "After
On" is not just a book,
it's a podcast.
ROB REID: It is now.
CHRIS DIBONA: It has
the same name, right?
ROB REID: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
CHRIS DIBONA: It's the
"After On" podcast,
focusing on the future--
ROB REID: The future,
yeah, the near future.
CHRIS DIBONA: --of things.
So we should have time for
questions at the very end
if you like.
And I'm just going to
hand it over to Rob.
And thank you so much for coming
and talking here at Google.
ROB REID: Thank
you for having me.
All right.
So just a quick intro
on what the story is.
As you guys have all
seen in the corner,
this is the book,
although yours will not
come with Post-it notes.
Those are for me.
It's called "After
On," and it's basically
the story of an imaginary
startup based up
in San Francisco.
It is set in almost
present-day San Francisco.
It's actually set nine
seconds into the future.
So whenever you start
reading this book,
it takes place
nine seconds hence.
So it is incumbent on the
reader to read very rapidly,
lest it be set in the past.
And as you can see,
it's a thick book,
so that's going
to be a challenge.
And this company is called,
Phluttr, P-H-L-U-T-T-R,
because we know how to spell.
It kind of embodies everything
that's wrong with social media,
maybe dialed up by about 20%.
So we're in the world of satire,
but definitely not the world
of farce.
And this is going to sound like
a spoiler, but it really isn't.
About midway through the book,
Phluttr attains consciousness.
And I say it's not
really a spoiler,
because you're going to
see that coming almost
from the first page.
And being a social
network, it doesn't
turn into some
kind of terminator
that wants to kill us all
because it is a social network.
So it becomes something
far more frightening,
which is basically--
excuse me, I'm getting
over a cough-- basically,
a hyper-empowered,
super-intelligent, 14-year-old
mean girl, basically--
but super-intelligent.
And that's kind of the character
that Phluttr enters the world
with initially.
Now, I'm going to talk about
the book in great detail
in a moment.
But first, I'm going to
give you a quick structure--
overview of what my
remarks are going to be.
I'm going to talk briefly
about my own background
because that feeds into this
book an enormous amount.
Then I'm going to
talk about how I dealt
with the science and
the tech, and also
some geopolitical issues
that are in the book.
Because it is basically
present day, and I wanted
that stuff to be as
accurate as possible.
And in fact, a
couple of Googlers
helped me try to ground
things in the present day.
Then I'm going to
talk briefly about how
the story is told because it's
told in a somewhat unusual way.
And I think it's
kind of fun and it's
grounded in the way we
consume media today.
And then I'm going to
talk maybe a little bit
about the dialogue
that I see happening
in society over the decades
between science and science
fiction, or between technology
and science fiction, which
I think is really healthy,
and maybe a couple of ideas
about how we might be
able to step that up.
And I will probably read little
bits and pieces of the book
through here.
And I say that with
some trepidation.
You go to a normal book
reading, people often
comment that the worst
thing about the reading
is the actual
reading of the book.
I'd say it's usually the wine
if you're at a bookstore,
because it's usually
like $1.00 a gallon,
and that's got it's
own sort of traumas.
But I'm going to weave in
a little bit of reading.
And then we'll hopefully
have time for Q&A.
So first of all, a little
bit about my background.
As Chris noted, I am
kind of from your world.
Not a company of
this scale, but I
was a venture-backed
entrepreneur
for a period of time.
I was briefly a VC.
I created the Rhapsody
music service,
which was kind of Spotify
before it was Spotify.
We were the first company
to get full catalog licenses
from all the major music labels
to distribute music online.
And we did basically create
the unlimited streaming model
that Spotify and Apple and
many others have since adopted.
I ended up selling that company
and became a tech investor
and I think it's fair to
say, basically started
meddling in my wife's
career quite a bit.
She, at the time, was
hosting a TV show that
covered the world of video
games and video gaming,
and we were living
down in Los Angeles,
this city built on storytelling.
And I had always been very, very
interested in writing fiction.
And at some point, I think maybe
she got tired of my meddling
in her career, and she
basically commanded
me to sit down and
write my first novel.
That was called "Year Zero."
This was kind of based on
my experiences at Rhapsody
to a certain
degree, in that it's
the tale of this vast
alien civilization that's
so into American pop music
that they accidentally commit
the biggest copyright
infringement since the dawn
of time, and thereby
bankrupt the entire universe.
And it's based on a
true story, by the way.
And so that was my first novel.
And I thought it was just
something I was doing, really,
for myself.
I thought it was something
so weird and so unusual
that maybe Larry Lessig
and my wife would read it
and nobody else.
But I had an agent because I'd
written a couple of business
books before.
I got it in front of the
folks at Random House
and they ended up publishing it.
And it actually-- very
briefly and barely,
sort of like a prairie dog--
got onto "The New York
Times" best seller list
for the shortest period of
time-- which is a week--
that's possible.
And I think it was, like,
number 23 out of 25, so barely.
But that was good enough for
Random House to say keep at it,
and so I started
writing this book.
It's unusual-- and in fact,
I might be the only person
who's done it--
to transition from the
venture-backed startup world
to writing fiction.
Now, lots and lots
of entrepreneurs
write books, write nonfiction.
I don't know of anybody else
who's made the transition
to writing serious fiction.
Although there could well be
somebody out there, and if so,
I'd love to meet them.
Now there's upsides
and downsides to that.
I mean, the downside
is it kind of
sucks that when you go
to one of those meet-ups
for entrepreneurs who have
turned into novelists,
you're inevitably
the only one there.
On the positive side, though,
it's really good for new-ish
novelists-- and this
is only my second book,
so I consider myself
to be new-ish--
to really focus on
that which we know.
And we are at a time when I
think society is very, very
interested in our
world out here, which
I try to depict very vividly and
very accurately in this book.
The world of entrepreneurs
and investors,
and the crazy relationship
certain products
might have with the
press and beyond.
The geniuses that inhabit and
populate and work for companies
like yours and so forth.
That's often depicted
in a way that's
just very fanciful
by folks who've never
spent a day in a tech company.
I will definitely
except HBO's TV series,
though, which often is
hysterically spot-on.
But a great deal
of the storytelling
out there really,
really misses the point.
And this is at a time
when society, I think,
finds us very interesting, and
our significance to broader
society is becoming
really significant.
And I think the better
our story is told,
and the better that it's
reflected out there, frankly--
hopefully-- the less people
will fear us on a certain level,
or at least the better
they'll understand us
and that which we do.
So that's something that
I think is kind of cool.
So that's one element
of my background
that's deeply, deeply
embedded in this book,
and it's the most obvious thing.
[COUGHING] Excuse me.
Now the second thing is
I spent a huge amount
of my time of my early adulthood
roaming around the Middle East,
including a year as a Fulbright
scholar in Cairo, Egypt.
I went all over the place.
I've been to Syria,
I've been to Lebanon.
I went to Iraq under
Saddam, Jordan, Gaza--
all over the place.
Since I was living there-- and
I got to the point where I spoke
reasonably good Arabic, although
it's rusted a lot since then--
since coming back, I try
to get back to the region
at least once a year.
And I've worked as an
elections observer.
I work as a pro bono advisor
to a lot of startups out there.
I work with a
not-for-profit out there.
And a certain element of my
background in the Middle East
comes into the book, as well.
Because issues of nihilistic
terrorism and what causes it
and what could prevent it--
and lone wolf terrorism,
in particular--
are prominent in the book.
It was something that impacted
me kind of tangentially.
Somebody that I used to spend
a lot of time with in Cairo
was actually assassinated
shortly after I left.
And Cairo had been a
very, very peaceful place
until the early '90s.
And it was really when this
associate of mine, Farag Foda,
was assassinated that
kind of touched off
a fairly violent period
in Egypt's history.
So that's something that I've
thought about quite a bit
over the decades, frankly.
And the third thing
is, I'm actually
a proud alum of the New York
City foster care system.
And issues of parental
ties and familial belonging
are quite big in the book.
So those three themes
are the sinews that
come together in this book.
And again, as a new-ish writer,
one does write what one knows.
And I think that's an exotic
enough mix that it leads
to a fairly unusual story.
Now as I mentioned, I
did a ton of digging
into the science and technology
that imbues this book.
Because writing something
that's present tense--
there's quite a
temptation, I think,
writers of speculative
fiction have,
to create things that
are just flat-out
magical from the standpoint
of present-day technology,
inject them into the storyline.
It can make your story a
much easier thing to tell.
But I kind of think that's
irresponsible storytelling,
and it's particularly
irresponsible in the realm
of speculative fiction.
Because I think
there's a presumption
on the part of at least
some of our readers
that they're learning stuff
about how the world really
works, and how technology
really works, particularly
if the book is set
in the present day.
Or at least that's
how I approach things.
And so the first
thing that I did
as I started writing this
thing is I conducted, actually,
hundreds of hours of
interviews with lots of folks
who were deep in the various
realms I wanted to cover.
And I'll add, this is one of
the coolest things about being
a science fiction writer.
I mean, if you call up a
relatively prominent scientist
or technologist and say,
hey, I'm a journalist
and I'm writing a story,
you might get a call back.
If you say, hey, I'm a
podcaster and I really
want to interview you--
I've been doing a bit
of that myself lately--
you might get a call back.
Man, if you call up and say,
I'm a science fiction writer
and I want to get your input
on a new novel, it's about 90%.
So you get really
good access to people.
Because I think a lot of folks
grew up on science fiction
and there's something kind
of fun about being involved
in the creation of that.
So the areas that I
dove into particularly
that I hadn't known much
about getting into this.
One was how might a
super AI actually arise?
I didn't know a whole lot about
neuroscience or consciousness
theory at the time.
I spent a lot of time with a
diversity of neuroscientists,
none more than a guy at UCSF
named Adam Gazzaley, who's
doing fascinating work.
And if you're interested in the
cutting edge of neuroscience,
particularly as it
associates to video games
and how it might impact
neuroplasticity and help
us fight horrors like
Alzheimer's disease and autism
and ADHD, there's lots and lots
of talks on the net by Adam.
And he became a great
mentor and informant to me
as I was writing this.
And in fact, his work has
been on the cover of "Nature,"
which, I'm sure, as a
lot of you guys know,
is a really, really big deal.
When I was researching quantum
computing, another major topic
in this book, I
spent a lot of time
with Google's own Hartmut Neven.
And he corrected a lot of
laughable misperceptions
I had about quantum
computing, which
was a really cool education.
And I remain very
grateful to him.
Synthetic biology is
a major theme here.
I'm sure many of you either
know, or at least know of,
Jeff Huber, who I've
known for decades.
At the time, he was
running life sciences--
I believe, I might get the
title a little bit off--
at Google X. He was a
great source for me.
So what was cool about this
is I got all of this learning
as a result of writing
this book, which
is the joy, for me,
of writing any book.
And I've written
nonfiction as well.
And obviously, you learn a
lot from writing nonfiction.
And then I start
writing this thing.
As you guys can see,
it is not short.
You should have seen
the first draft.
The first draft was
about 800 pages long.
And I handed it in
to Random House.
They're like, we're
going to chop down
a forest for this thing.
So it was clear that I
needed to rein it in.
And the thing that I was most
guilty of is when I learned
about a domain of science
or tech or geopolitics--
because I learned a lot
more about certain domains
in geopolitics--
when I got deep
into something, I
was all too likely to just,
in the middle of the story--
and the car is about
to go off the cliff,
and let me tell you about
how cool synthetic biology is
for 20 pages.
You end up hijacking your story.
And the more you know about
something as a novelist,
the more inclined
you are to do that,
so I kind of had this problem.
Because I really
wanted to infuse
all this stuff in the book,
but I was hijacking my story.
So what I ended up doing--
and I don't know if any other
fiction writer has done this.
And again, there probably
are some out there
and hopefully, I'll find others.
Because again, the
meet-ups are just me.
But what I decided to do
is create a podcast series
to accompany the book, in
which I could do really, really
deep interviews with
domain experts in seven
or eight areas that are
most germane to the book.
So I could go into the--
in many cases, not all--
but in many cases, I was
interviewing the person
who had been such a great sort
of mentor and informant to me
as I was doing my research.
So I started putting
these podcasts out
when the book came out.
The book came out last month.
And the eighth one
went up, actually,
I guess, last night
or the night before.
And it's about
Fermi's paradox, which
is this really cool thing
in astronomy, which is
like, where are all the aliens?
It's actually a very
scientifically significant
question.
Why can we not see signs of
extraterrestrial intelligence?
So you're into that, I've
got a two-hour conversation
with a British astronomer
on the web now.
It might be the
longest conversation
about Fermi's paradox
ever recorded.
If it's not, I'm sure it's
the longest one ever podcast.
But anyway, so I'm able
to get really, really
deep with these podcasts.
And I did one on
augmented reality,
I did one on quantum computing.
I certainly did one on super
AI risk, et cetera, et cetera.
So that's kind of how I
dealt with the science
and technology.
Now the last thing, or the
second-to-last thing I told you
I'd talk about-- and this is
where I'll start sprinkling
in some readings--
how the story is told.
So it's great that you guys have
the physical book because you
can flip through it
and see that there
are a lot of very different
type settings going on in here.
And the reason is,
about 75% of the book
is told in the form of
a traditional narrative.
There's some flashbacks.
It's primarily set
in the present day.
There's a chunk of stuff that
happens right after the bubble
burst-- the internet
bubble, around 2002--
where half of the characters
are still in high school,
and the other half are
kind of young entrepreneurs
that are freaking out and
saying, what just happened?
So there's a little
bit of flashbacks.
There's mainly
traditional narrative.
But the rest of the
book is told through all
these different media types.
There are 18 Amazon
reviews in this book.
Yes, really.
And the story is genuinely
told partly through them.
There's lots of tweets.
There's SMS's.
There's five or six very, very
voicey bloggers, some of them
very angry about certain things,
that are blogging in there.
There are excerpts from
a second novel, which
are a little bit mysterious when
they first start showing up.
I put probably a dozen, or maybe
a little bit fewer, excerpts
in the book.
I'm quite convinced
if I finished
writing this second
novel, it would
be literally the single
worst science fiction
novel ever written.
But they're in there
for storytelling reasons
and also for playful reasons.
And so that was kind
of a cool thing,
to weave all this
stuff together.
Now I'll tell you
guys, I'm going
to read one of my Amazon reviews
because I think the Amazon
reviews are kind of fun.
And they actually have an
interesting back story.
So when I was running Rhapsody--
or the company that built
Rhapsody, I should say--
it was really stressful.
I actually didn't think I was
a particularly good manager.
I kept that a really
good secret for a while,
but eventually, it
started getting out.
And every night, after I
was done with all my email,
and all my managerial
responsibilities,
I'd kind of sit there and do
this self-indulgent thing,
and it was actually writing
these insane Amazon reviews.
This was back in 2002.
And I took on the persona of
this sort of insane Bostonian--
Charles Henry Higginsworth
III, of Boston, Massachusetts--
who would start writing
these Amazon reviews.
And he'd get about a
third of the way in there,
and then he'd do this
180 and start just
bitching about his life.
And he was from this
formerly wealthy family that
had blown all its
money, and they
were living in this crumbling
mansion on Beacon Hill
and they didn't even have
money for heating oil
because some great aunt had
spent the last of the money
or something like that.
And he had this really
sort of pompous voice
that I just had fun writing.
And so I started writing
all these Amazon reviews.
I almost became a
top 1,000 reviewer.
How cool would that have been?
Answer-- very.
I didn't, though.
And so when I started creating
this book all these years
later, I realized I wanted
a certain character--
as a minor character, but a
significant character-- that
had a certain set of traits.
I'm like, oh, my god, I
want Mr. Higginsworth.
And by the way, yes, please
use Mr. when you refer to him.
He prefers it that way.
And so I started weaving in his
Amazon reviews, all of which
are still up on
Amazon, dated 2002.
So I think some people think
this is like "Boyhood."
Oh, my god, he's been
working on this for 15 years.
Not true.
But I did repurpose
my Amazon reviews.
So this is one of them.
This is a review about--
and it does relate, I swear,
to the plot of the book.
This is Mr. Charles
Henry Higginsworth III
of Boston,
Massachusetts, reviewing
a book called "Time to Make the
Donuts, The Founder of Dunkin'
Donuts Shares an
American Journey."
So here it is.
His title of his review--
"From the Kitchens of Boston
to Your Left Ventricle"
is the title of the review.
Five stars, by Charles
Henry Higginsworth III.
I kind of felt morally
obliged to rate everything
five stars because in
most cases back then,
I hadn't actually read
these books, so you know.
So he says, "Like a charmed
wind hurling vital provisions
on a castaway's
beach, fate landed
a copy of this in
our conference room,
in which I served a recent
sentence to traffic school.
As reading was a scorned pastime
amongst my fellow inmates,
I laid easy claim to
the volume, a mental sop
for a mind numbed by
the day's prattle.
I was soon swept up by this tale
of an intrepid entrepreneur's
rise to the heights of the
glamorous but cutthroat world
of donut retail.
I meanwhile enjoyed no
small surge of civic pride,
Dunkin' Donuts having
sprung from the loins
of my own native Boston.
The narrative is sprinkled
with little-known truths
about this breakfast staple.
For instance, did you know
that the modern word 'donut'
descends from dough
not, which itself
traces lineage to the
archaic dough knot?
Nor did I, sir, nor did I.
Short on complex formulae
and your lengthier words,
this is ideal reading at
events at which attention
must be feigned.
But be advised,
this could impair
the absorption of important
lessons from without.
I myself learned
this the hard way
when I caused a minor accident
upon leaving the traffic
school's driveway by
failing to signal,
neglecting a major leitmotiv
from the day's curriculum.
My instructor, who had
resented my divided attention
throughout the day,
savored the irony."
What a pompous jerk, right?
So anyway, that ended up
getting stitched into the book.
And now one of the cool
things about having--
OK, so the reason that I brought
all these different media
elements in, just to back up,
is I feel that this is the way
we engage in stories today.
It's the way we engage in
news stories as they unfold.
In some ways, it's
even the way that we
engage in narrative stories.
Because we might be watching
snippets of something,
but we're watching it on demand,
so we watch three minutes here
and four minutes there.
And then we might end up reading
a summary of that episode
somewhere online, and then
kind of go back to it.
I feel like this barrage
of snippets of media,
of texts, of blogs,
of Amazon reviews
and the rest is kind of the way
that we inhale the world today.
And the novel itself really is
primarily-- the earliest ones
go back to the 17th
and 18th century--
but it's really a 19th century
invention, for the most part.
That's when it really
came into its own.
And the attention
spans that we had,
and the way that we engaged
in relationship and careers
and everything else was
so much more linear,
and start-to-finish,
and so much more focused
that I thought it would
be kind of fun to inject
some of these elements into this
ancient mode of storytelling.
Now another dimension of
it which is kind of neat
is when you have all these
different storytelling
elements when you
do an audiobook,
you can recruit all kinds of
very distinct and different
voices to that audiobook.
So these Amazon reviews, of
which there are about a dozen
and a half-- and I cannot do
justice to the reading compared
to the actual reader-- are
all read by a guy named John
Hodgman, who is a
brilliant comedian.
He was very frequently
on "The Daily Show."
He's been in lots of
TV series and movies.
He is perhaps best known for
those famous commercials,
"I'm a Mac, I'm a PC."
If you remember those from
some years back, he was the PC.
He is Bostonian and he
just reads these reviews
in this really wonderful kind
of stentorian, pompous voice.
I just did my best, but
I'm not as good as him.
Felicia Day is beloved
by lots of geeks
for having created "The Guild,"
that wonderful web series,
and done a lot of other things.
She was frequently in
"Buffy the Vampire Slayer."
These days, she's in "Mystery
Science Theater 3000. "
She was a voice of
one of my bloggers.
If anybody listens to
"This Week in Tech,"
Leo Laporte is the voice of
the "San Francisco Chronicle."
Tom Merritt is the voice
of "The New York Times."
Patrick Rothfuss, who writes
amazing fantasy novels,
including "The
Name of the Wind"--
just read it, trust
me on that one--
has also got this great big
kind of-- he can do these rants,
these playful rants in
this over-the-top manner.
So he read that crazy
awful science fiction
novel that's excerpted in here.
And so you can have a
lot of fun with audio.
And audiobooks are really
coming in their own as a medium
right now.
Audiobooks are growing
at something like--
probably 10 times the
speed of publishing itself.
My last novel was about
4 and 1/2 years ago.
When this came out, the folks
at Random House Audio told me,
their business is up over
300% in 4 and 1/2 years, which
is more like tech
rates of growth, which
is another interesting topic.
So that is the way
the story is told.
Now the other thing that I do
that's a little bit unusual--
and I'll do a slightly
longer reading right now,
and it will piss you off-- or
it should, it's intended to.
There's this weird
narrator that appears
at the very, very
beginning of the book,
and then kind of
stands back a bit,
and kind of comes
in periodically
to just sort of jab you and
say, don't forget about me,
I'm still here.
So it is a book with a narrator,
but it's a very, very soft
touch narrator.
And again, it's not
unique, but it's
something that's a little bit
unusual, that I do for reasons
that kind of become
evident, I'd say,
not until the very, very end
of the book, so don't peek.
The narrator is actually not
revealed until the last two
or three pages.
But I'm going to read the
opening page and a half or so,
which is when this
narrative voice--
maybe a little longer-- yeah,
about a page and a half--
is most present.
Then I'm going to say a
couple things about it.
So this is how the book starts,
starting from the first word.
"Some people think all great
books should start with a dare.
And those folks
can't be big readers,
because really, when
was the last time
you read a book that
began with a dare?
Well, this one does.
And that's not some ham-fisted
gambit to position it as great.
Because we just established that
only half-literates conflate
opening dares with greatness.
So it's truly just
a simple dare.
And it's this.
I dare you to finish the fucker.
And let's be real,
you probably won't.
It's 547 pages
printed, after all,
which is to say any number of
locations, sections, or lit
nodes in your e-reader.
And its obnoxious
length is nothing
compared to the
disquieting truths
it reveals about a popular
social/messaging/hookup
platform that humanity
already spends
11.2% of its online
time engaged with,
about who really built
all of that and why,
about who's listening and
what they're recording.
And here's the
part that may smart
a bit, how terribly
uninteresting
they almost certainly find you.
There's also some
truly scary stuff
you just don't need to know
about the February bombing
in San Francisco,
about how it actually
saved lives, lots of them,
and quite possibly your own.
And about how
moronically close we
came to a nuclear war with
China on a recent winter's day.
Spoiler alert--
not my fault. You
don't have to know any of
this, and ignoring the hidden
ugliness we can't do much
about makes life easier.
So if you tend to avoid
facts like the age of the kid
who stitched your favorite
blazer just outside of Phnom
Penh, or how athletically a
certain ex once cheated on you,
or how painful and scary
the last few days of most
human lives are, then for
God's sake, put the book down.
And do yourself a
big favor and catch
a movie, a numbered sequel,
say, starring cartoon men
invented to distract tots
during the Roosevelt era.
You'll find that plenty
challenging and much more fun.
It will also be
over sooner, leaving
you free for more
numbered sequels,
or maybe some of the
light sci-fi written
for the bright teens and dim
grownups we euphemistically
call young adults.
Are you still there?
If so, I'm sorry if
that sounded a bit mean,
but we're better off with
whoever just stomped off.
Those people offend easily.
They're always
whining about how they
feel unsafe or under-cherished
if their every clumsy kick,
catch, and volley isn't
commemorated with trophies.
I can't stand those people.
I bet you can't
stand them either.
So getting rid of them was
worth feigning contempt
for some of my own
favorite things.
Psst, two of the best
movies ever, in my view,
are "Iron Man" 1 and 2.
Also, I read YA
stuff constantly.
I bet you didn't know that.
Now that it's just
us, I applaud you
for at least attempting
to see this thing through.
Even you probably
won't get there--
those 547 pages, again--
but if you do, I can
make you three promises.
One, I will never
talk down to you.
Yes, certain facts herein are
hard to confront and accept.
Certain others are
hard to understand.
But I think you're man
enough, woman enough,
or young adult enough
to handle it all.
So no sugarcoating
and no dumbing down.
Two, I'll never lie to you.
Everything that follows,
however fantastical
and hard to believe,
is entirely true,
and precisely depicts
the underpinnings
of the world you inhabit.
And finally, at the very,
very end of all this,
you will find a
glittering prize.
Books that end with
glittering prizes
are even rarer than those that
start with dares, so lucky you.
But please, no peeksies.
With that, I'm
almost done with you.
And that may be welcome news.
My tone can grate a bit, I know.
It's probably just a
phase I'm going through.
But I'll give you
your space now.
That said, I will check
in every so often,
sometimes when you least
expect it, as the hit men say.
And of course, I'll
be back at the end,
with that glittering
prize of yours.
And you'd thought I'd
already forgotten.
But for now, let's
begin our story
with some quick opening
praise for the women
and men of Silicon Valley.
Yes, yes, I know, but those
fuckers gave us "Farmville."
It's true, and everyone's
awfully sorry about that.
But at its best, the Valley
remains an inspiring land,
almost bewitchingly so.
I mean, where else can a handful
of misfits meet up in a garage,
share mad bolts of inspiration,
then mainline Red Bull,
sleep under desks, code
on bleeding fingers
until they hack together an
agenda-setting product that
will rock the world?
And then register
their millionth user
in just weeks, their 10
millionth in mere months,
and forge friendships
and talents
that will last a lifetime,
all while getting
vastly, shamelessly,
pornographically rich?
The answer, of course, is
Austin, Seattle, Beijing,
London, Oslo, Bangalore,
Seoul, Nairobi, Dubai, Buenos
Aires, and quite possibly
Perth, Australia,
among countless other places.
But this sort of thing happens
on a grander scale in Silicon
Valley than anywhere else.
And the cliche is dead accurate.
We're designing the future here.
We also designed the
present, and you're
much better off for that.
Snort at this if
you must, but do you
really want to go back to six
broadcast channels, CB radios,
typewriters, dominoes, and
checkers, rotary phones,
and thermostats that don't even
speak a single word of English?
Didn't think so.
So yes, Silicon Valley
did give us "Farmville,"
but across the decades,
its countless startups
have also rebuilt our
world's foundations.
Some relentlessly advanced
the microprocessor,
enabling the digital wonders
of our era, others home DNA
sequencing, which
cracked the human genome,
and will one day
help to cure cancer.
Still others pioneered
wireless technologies
that are finally patching
together the world's poorest
sectors into a global
super-plex of information.
Literally thousands of
Silicon Valley startups
in these and countless
fields have advanced humanity
in palpable ways.
And no matter how you cut
it, however imaginatively,
generously, even
schizophrenically you
look at things, [? giftishly ?]
was never ever one of them.
Nope, not even close."
So then we talk about
[? giftishly. ?]
Now every time I
read these pages,
I want to strangle my narrator
because I find the tone so
spectacularly obnoxious,
which is good because I
worked very, very hard on that.
And like I said, and like
the narrator promised,
the narrator said, I know
my tone can grate a bit,
I'll get out of your way.
The narrator does that.
But like I said, comes back
from time to time to poke you.
And I'd like to say
more about the narrator
but I'd give
certain things away.
So I'm going to close just with
a quick note on the dialogue
that I think we've
had as a society--
and as a world of
creators on my side,
and as a world of creators of
tech and science on your side,
and formerly kind of my side--
between science and science
fiction, and technology
and science fiction.
Just a show of hands,
how many folks,
at some point much
earlier in your life,
before you decided
to enter tech,
were in some way inspired
by science fiction,
and maybe attribute
your presence now here
at Google to some inspiration
from science fiction
when you were young?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, yeah.
So it's about half, and
that's generally what I find.
I mean, it is
something that I think
can be very, very powerful.
And I feel the science fiction
that personally intrigued
me the most when I was a kid--
I loved super deep
future stuff, things
that pointed to things
that were improbable
ever, and certainly not going
to happen in my lifetime.
But the things that got
me most excited, and then
pointed me-- although I studied
Arabic and Middle Eastern
history in college.
I wasn't an engineer-- but
drew me to the industry--
were those stories
that were told
kind of in the intermediate
future, that really,
really excited me about
what might happen.
And so I've been talking to
a couple of people, including
this gentleman, Adam
Gazzaley, who I mentioned
to you, about maybe
trying to create sort
of like a semi-formal
council-like thing
between creators
of science fiction
and creators of
science and technology,
where maybe we could
pair up in some way
and maybe get groups
of people to create
short stories that maybe we
release on an annual basis,
where there's a scientist
or a technologist teamed up
with a science fiction writer.
We set things in that
10 to 25-year frame,
which can be so inspiring.
So I think there's
really two things
that people who write
about the future can do.
One-- and we've been doing less
and less of this recently--
we can depict the future
that we want to inhabit.
And science fiction used
to do a lot more of that.
Science fiction used to be much
more optimistic than I'd say it
is now.
Dystopianism has just
pervaded the field, really
in the last 25 years.
But that optimistic
message is very important,
but so is the dystopian one.
Because I think works
of speculative fiction
also depict the
worlds we absolutely
do not want to inhabit
under any circumstances.
And I would say there was a
lot of magnificent storytelling
during the Cold War that did
a lot to freak out hundreds
of millions or
billions of people
about how bad a nuclear war
could actually be, things
set in the near future then.
And I think that helped us avoid
that fate, at least until now.
And I'd also give George Orwell
an enormous amount of credit.
We don't really
think of "1984" today
as being a work of science
fiction, but it was.
He wrote it in 1948, and
things like telescreens
and so forth were way beyond
the technology of the day.
And you could be forgiven,
as a smart person in 1948,
looking at the
world and thinking
that a completely totalitarian
future was all but inevitable.
Because on the left, you'd
had Stalin and the horrors
that he perpetrated.
On the right, you had
Hitler, and the horrors
that he perpetrated.
Clearly, a
totalitarian regime was
going to take over
China at that point.
And it looked like we
were heading for that.
And I think that "1984"
freaked out, again,
hundreds of millions
of people about how
bad this future really could be
when combined with technology
that was then right on the
horizon, video conferencing
and video dissemination.
So I think he helped us
not inhabit that future.
And I think that's
an important mission
for science and
technology-based storytelling.
And the more that that can be
done in sort of a partnership
between the writers and the
people who genuinely create
the future-- it sure ain't us--
the better.
So those are my quick
words on this crazy book.
I'm open to any questions.
And yeah, fire away.
AUDIENCE: I just started
watching the Vietnam series
that Ken Burns is doing.
ROB REID: It's magnificent.
AUDIENCE: Right?
Started last night.
ROB REID: It's amazing.
AUDIENCE: Episode
one, and I'm thinking,
wow, there's going to
be 14 hours of this.
So your book contains all
these tools and exchanges
and contexts that we now
enjoy that are seconds long,
and maybe minutes, rarely hours.
It's kind of interesting.
What are you thinking about--
like, what is it that
Ken Burns says, gee, I'm
going to make this
thing 20 hours long
and people will love it?
ROB REID: Well, hey, Ken,
this is 22 hours long.
No, and it's a similar mindset,
that I think that anybody who
creates very, very long
form entertainment,
we're really battling
horrific headwinds.
And so I think I can speak
very, very directly to that.
I mean, the audiobook of
this is 22 hours long,
and it's 547 pages, 191,000
words according to my word
processor, in an
era that lionizes
the 140-character tweet.
And I mean, I think that
if you are dedicated
to this level of
depth, you better not
be in it for the money.
Now I think Ken Burns has done
very, very well over the years
by telling historical
stories brilliantly well.
But I think A, you better
not be in it for the money
and you better have an
extraordinary commitment
to this very, very long form
that you're engaging in.
And I think secondly, it's
really incumbent upon you
to use the medium to convey
a message that simply can't
be conveyed in other ways.
And I think that--
again, to go 19th century,
or even the 1950s or '60s--
there was probably more
call for a novel that really
just conveyed the
type of experience
that you could get from
watching playful TV
or something like that.
In an era now, where people have
so many claims on their time
and intelligence, and there's
so many brilliant ways to spend
that time--
I mean, TV has
never been better.
I'd say film has been better,
but TV has never been better.
Really, if you're going
to make a statement that's
20 hours long, you
better make a statement
that simply couldn't be
conveyed in another manner.
And Sam Harris has a very
interesting and, at times,
controversial podcast.
I actually interviewed
him for my own podcast.
We had a two-hour interview
a couple episodes ago.
He had Ken Burns on, I think his
last episode or the one before.
So it's the one
interview that I've heard
and he interviewed
him at great length.
And I think that Ken Burns,
based on the interview
that I heard, felt that he had
a story whose sweep and scope
simply could not be told
in less than 20 hours.
And therefore, it
was something that
merited this very big footprint,
very rarely deployed tool
that he had.
And I think that there is
absolutely call for the novel
and the 20-hour documentary
in this day and age.
And there is a very
interesting phenomenon.
We now have 13-hour movies,
for all intents and purposes--
the really wonderful
premium cable entertainment.
The great serialized things
that are going up on Netflix,
and Amazon, and now
Hulu-- and I know
you guys are doing some buying.
They really are
13-hour movies, I
mean, if you look at
something like "Breaking Bad."
That's something
that the distribution
and economic infrastructure
that we live in today enables.
And it turns out, people have
attention for 13-hour movies.
So I think that the very
long and very short--
I think there's room
for all attention spans.
I love listening to
sprawling audiobooks.
I love an audiobook that
clocks in at 20-30 hours.
Because sometimes, I
listen on 2x speed.
As a New Yorker,
I do a huge amount
of walking and subwaying,
and I've got a little dog.
And boy, New York's the
land of 1,000 walks for her.
And being able to really
steep in something that long--
it's also interesting there's
some very, very long podcasts
out there.
Sam Harris and Tim Ferriss--
I cite them because they rhyme--
but they're also
both very popular.
They tend to have these one,
two, three-hour conversations
that are very, very
popular podcasts.
So I think our attention
span is pretty robust.
And it really has
got to be targeting
that thing to the right amount.
And I love the fact that
the 140-character snippet
is vibrant, and is
connected to by billions.
That had no way to get into
the world until 10 years ago.
And it turns out we
actually have a lot
to say at that short time frame.
And I'm glad that the
world's media infrastructure
can accommodate that, too.
Thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]